c'est extraordinaire qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire c'est comme un film préféré
et vous fait rien de 6 ans vous armand
vaillancourt à 85 ans et toujours cette
même énergie folle et débridée partout
dans son atelier on trouve des oeuvres
des projets ici une étude pour une
immense sculpture destiné au 375e
anniversaire de la ville de montréal
pour l'instant il n'y a pas de preuves
pour aller voir le merle et voilà des
archives qui témoigne d'une carrière qui
s'étend sur plus de 60 ans
beaucoup d'articles de presse armand
vaillancourt a fait à quelques reprises
l'objet de reportages dans des grands
magazines américains pour une oeuvre sa
fameuse fontaine de san francisco
la voici à l'époque des beaux jours
cette fontaine qu'a construit armand
vaillancourt une gigantesque structure
entièrement de béton tout à côté du port
de san francisco vaillancourt a consacré
quatre années de travail en californie à
cette fontaine résolument moderne
l'eau coule à flots
mais aujourd'hui la source est tarie le
mugissement de la fontaine a laissé
place à un triste silence le robinet
fermé sécheresse oblige les touristes
regardent la fontaine sans trop savoir
de quoi il s'agit
serait-ce un amas de débris provenant
d'une quelconque démolition se demande
cet homme armand vaillancourt reste fier
de son oeuvre mais se désole de la
tournure des événements ouais je compte
à mes yeux pas content à quesnoy qui
l'empêchent de reculer alors que ça n'a
droit de l'aude touristique que cela
fera six côtés alors pourquoi pour faire
un effort places écoulées loool une
plaque sur l'oeuvre nous on indique que
le nom lafontaine vaillancourt mais
quand elle a été inaugurée en 71 armand
vaillancourt avait un autre nom en tête
un documentariste a retrouvé ses images
de l'inauguration où l'on voit
vaillancourt avec de la peinture et des
décalques baptisé sa fontaine québec
libre
le premier graffitis sur la fontaine
c'est l'artiste lui-même qui l'a
dessinée
aux états-unis en 71 on est en plein
mouvement de contestation guerre du
vietnam
black panthers affirmation autochtone
vaillancourt lui sort de la crise
d'octobre et à sa cause l'indépendance
du québec
une fontaine québec libre à san
francisco oui comment oui mais ça fait
tout de même la bonne place pour ça y'a
jamais la bonne place
cap et des militaires un autre qui a
découvert très vite qu'il n'y a jamais
de bonnes classes pour faire un graffiti
c'est bono en 87 lors d'un concert
gratuit
le chanteur de youtou monte sur la
fontaine est écrit à la peinture en
aérosol rock and stop ce trafic
ça a soulevé la colère des autorités de
san francisco comment cette vedette rock
hostel donner le mauvais exemple en
dessinant des graffitis sur une
propriété publique
ono se retrouve dans le pétrin et risque
la prison
alors pour se sortir de ce mauvais pas
que fait-il qu'il ya quelqu'un qui m'a
qui me téléphonent il dit mané mais my
name is bonobo miotto l'idée iguana
sperme et youtube bel - sans valeur
leurs deux fils saint-claude le singe en
question est vite vaillancourt à son
prochain spectacle à oakland en
californie trois jours plus tard bono
veut présenter ses excuses à
vaillancourt pour s'éviter les foudres
de la justice
il ya un beau nos lits dont tu as tu as
toi par le jazz pour votre cuisine
t'as pas d'appart excusé s'il a great
white bugs graphiques en profiter et
voilà qu'à aux clones de vaillancourt à
son tour fait des graffitis au rouleau
sur les décors de youtou pendant le
spectacle du groupe
ce sera suffisant bono n'est pas
poursuivi bien qu'ils maintiennent que
ce qu'il a fait sur la fontaine n'était
pas un graffiti mais de la bonne eau en
disait plus tard iam un artiste d'infos
c'est pas un graffiti mais via un seul
en chef et ce afin de créer un fois
appuyé et moi d'effroi le très radical
armand vaillancourt en a connu disons
quelques-uns dans sa vie à san francisco
par exemple les autorités en avaient
tellement assez du sculpteur québécois
que quand le projet fontaine a été
terminé ils ont rasé son atelier au
bulldozer
mais pourquoi en faisant rage au coeur
se venger il vous en voulez rhume à
faire promoters vaillancourt et radicale
bagarreur tirent dans toutes les
directions et on peut voir comment il a
pu se faire quelques ennemis les j'aime
mon travail mais il n'ya pas ma pensée
ce qui fait que je fais ce travail ce
que fait ce n'est pas chez pas travail
de [ __ ] que je fais là un travail de
d'une conscience sociale
dans ce même esprit armand vaillancourt
a un autre projet pour la grappe oil la
porte s'ouvrir à longueuil
ouais un langage une sculpture
monumentale le projet de 2 millions à la
mémoire des travailleurs et du
syndicaliste michel chartrand quatre ans
que je travaille sur ça mais parce qu'il
nous manque encore de bons madar 20,1
san francisco une sécheresse a fait
taire sa fontaine forbo victoire à
montréal
rien ne fera jamais taire armand
vaillancourt ils vous voient les gens
dans la rue un peu de monde qu'il pense
mais ça ne se passe pas non plus est ce
un problème